Я Чуднецов Євген Артурович, позивний у мене "Чудік".
Я бойовий медик на той момент полку "Азов"
і взагалі виконувач обов'язків начальника медичного пункту 2-го батальйону.
Я пішов воювати… ну, не воювати, а взагалі добровольцем, у 2014 році.
Тобто коли всі ці події Революції Гідності сталися у Києві,
я сидів у себе в місті, в Макіївці, просто дивився, можна сказати, по телевізору.
Я взагалі сподівався, що це все закінчиться, що влада,
яка була на той момент, вона все ж таки зможе ухвалити правильне рішення,
а не "Беркут" гнати на людей.
Вийшло не так. І взагалі те, що відбувалося в Донецькій області,
я думав, що побігають придурки з палками і розійдуться по домах.
Але воно потім почало як сніговий ком нарощуватися.
Взагалі, я виріс, у мене регіон такий російськомовний, родина російськомовна.
Те, що російськомовна - нехай, але регіон сам по собі "ватний".
Ну, і родина в мене така аполітична, але з "ватним" нахилом була.
І я такий же - дитина приймає на себе середовище з родини, з друзів.
Тому я до певного часу, коли навчався в школі, також був таких "ватних" поглядів.
Російські брати - отаке...
Мабуть, те, що середовище поміняв.
Почав спілкуватися, у нас у Донецьку був осередок "Патріоти України", я почав з хлопцями з "Патріотів України" спілкуватися.
Ну, і почав читати книжки, літературу українську.
А коли я вирішив, що все-таки треба брати до рук зброю,
- це коли зрозумів, що це само по собі не закінчиться, що це треба закінчувати.
Тобто сподіватися на якогось дядю, який прийде і тебе захистить…
Ну, взагалі є держава - це як єдиний організм. І кожна людина - це клітина цього організму.
Якщо деякі клітини захворіли, то або прийдуть фагоцити, які ці клітини нейтралізують,
або організм почне хворіти і помре. Ну, от ми і є такі клітини.
Це був кінець вересня, коли я приїхав до Маріуполя.
На той момент "Азов" був ще батальйоном міліції спеціального призначення.
Але наприкінці року він повинен був переходити у склад Національної гвардії України.
Тому я вирішив відкласти своє оформлення офіційне, щоб одразу вже підписати контракт.
Були такі бої, що Широкине, я був у Широкиному на той момент,
воно переходило по декілька разів із рук в руки - це за день. І такий хаос.
І, пригадую, 14 лютого, зранку був обстріл артилерійський,
і сепаратисти зробили там танковий прорив, почали танки по селу кататися.
Я просто чув, як працює "двіжок" танковий.
Я розумію, що туди поїхав мені в спину, я думаю: що таке?
Потім назад поїхав. Я розумію, що вже часу пройшло, треба виходити.
Почав виходити, розвернувся в сторону наших позицій, там пробіг один двір, третій,
до третього добіг, забіг у двір прямо, а там "сепари" були вже.
Мої рідні отак дізналися, що я взагалі був в "Азові", коли з'явилося відео, що я в полоні.
Ну, і розумніше за все, що вони могли зробити, це мене, звісно, вбити.
Але їм там зверху сказали, щоб мене привезли, бо це була гарна медійна картинка така.
Тобто "азовців", я на той момент був єдиний полонений "азовець", ну і вони хотіли так вдарити по пропаганді.
Ну, звісно, що дали мені такий блок, якісь запитання будуть ставити,
сказали обов'язково, щоб я вставив у свою промову, звісно, про іноземне озброєння, про іноземних інструкторів.
У першому полоні я пробув майже три роки. З 14 лютого 2015 року по 27 грудня 2017-го.
Ну, і взагалі, я там був, я ж був засуджений.
Для так званої "ДНР" я являвся ким?
Просто злочинцем, звичайно.
Мені 20 років строгого режиму по одній статті і 18 по іншій.
Тобто разом 38. Ну, там, так як "правосуддя" ДНР дуже милосердне,
вони 8 років мені скосили шляхом часткового поєднання двох статтей
мені дали 30 років строгого режиму і 3 роки надзору.
Прокурорка спочатку вимагала вищу міру покарання.
Мій перший полон взагалі, скажу так, він пройшов дуже лайтово,
якщо б не оці нюанси перших двох днів.
Які нюанси - це вирвані зуби плоскогубцями, ну, і там, розбите обличчя.
27 грудня 2017 року мене обміняли.
Був на співбесіді з командиром на той момент вже полку - з другом Редісом.
Поспілкувалися, він запитав, чи я буду продовжувати військову службу, чи хочу звільнитися.
Я сказав, що хочу продовжувати.
По-перше, війна на той момент і зараз у нас ще не закінчилася.
Звісно, я вирішив продовжувати військову службу.
Війна не закінчилася, справи, в принципі, не дороблені.
Тобто, ми не деокупували всі території.
Бої в Маріуполі - це було...
Так, це було дуже складно. Дуже складно в якому плані?
Це дуже складно в плані логістики.
Тобто, ми коли були вже в оточенні, складно в плані евакуації.
Найбільше це була логістика і евакуація, тому що ти в оточеному місті.
Ну, і взагалі міські бої, те, що було на іншій території нашій, не було таких боїв, як в Маріуполі.
Може, там зрівняти Бахмут, але Бахмут не таке місто, як Маріуполь.
Там не така кількість багатоповерхівок, не така територія.
А ми були в повному оточенні.
Я з самого початку, коли почалася повномасштабна війна,
я з самого початку знав, що це квиток в один кінець, що ми з Маріуполя не вийдемо.
Бої поступово почали наростати з такою інтенсивністю.
Те, що обстріли - то обстріли. Там не було такого місця в Маріуполі,
де не дістане артилерія чи не може прилетіти, тому що ми оточені, кругом вороги там.
І це ж працює не тільки артилерія та танки.
З цієї сторони артилерія, танки, тут же авіація, тут морська артилерія.
Тобто, це кораблі, катери ракетні, на яких стоять установки, і з моря тебе також обстрілюють.
Тобто місця, де може було сховатися, безпечного місця там не було.
Я навіть не уявляю, яка кількість загиблих у Маріуполі.
Думаю, що більше ніж 30 тисяч, це серед цивільного населення.
А потім, коли бої почали бути більш інтенсивними, то довелося провести евакуацію 555-го госпіталю,
він на завод Азовсталі перемістився. Ну, з пораненими, звісно, з обладнанням.
Це дуже було складно. Поранення були абсолютно різні.
Дуже складно було евакуацію проводити.
Скажу так: її не складно, в деяких моментах її було проводити неможливо.
Просто неможливо. І це було найскладніше: що поранені накопичуються, а тобі немає, куди їх подіти.
Ну, звісно, що такий досвід, який був в нас в Маріуполі,
є не в кожній армії світу, які взагалі писали ці протоколи.
Тому вони також і цікавляться таким досвідом, який був у нас.
Бо вони зацікавлені в тому, щоб оновлювати свої протоколи, в тому числі з тактичної медицини.
Це те, що я за своїм фахом можу сказати.
І тому вони цікавляться, бо їх пролонговані протоколи домедичної допомоги розраховані на добу,
на дві, але не на такі умови, коли ти два тижні не можеш евакуацію провести.
Просто війна така, яка була в Маріуполі, вона багато що може дати і багато чому навчити,
але дуже швидко доводиться реагувати на обставини, які дуже швидко змінюються.
Тебе зараз були одні умови, через 5 хвилин вони в тебе інші.
А в таких обставинах треба готуватися до найгіршого.
Коли ти готувався до найгіршого, а ми готувалися до найгіршого, то ти, в принципі, був вже готовий.
Коли виходили ми з Азовсталі, я провів, організував цю евакуацію поранених.
Звісно, що в першій хвилі йдуть найтяжчі, лежачі бійці, життю чи здоров'ю яких є загроза.
Вони в першу категорію в мене потрапили на евакуацію.
Їх супроводжував хірург 555-го військового шпиталю - це Денис Гайдук.
А потім друга хвиля - це в мене були поранені, у яких там є навіть і ампутація,
але їхнє життя не висить на нитці і нема загрози в даний момент, але які потребують допомоги при евакуації.
І третє - це такі найбільш легкі поранення, це навіть поранені, які з ампутацією,
але він може самостійно пересуватися на двох своїх ногах,
навіть без руки вони допомагали іншим побратимам.
І вже в останню чергу, це 20 травня, це ми виходили.
Ну, там взагалі і командування, тобто, командування, звісно, в останню чергу, коли всі вже вийшли.
Ну, я в останню, тому що всіх поранених, а потім вже самі.
Нічого, знищив бункер, знищив засоби зв'язку, звісно, всі планшети, телефони і все інше.
Там, хто знає, як на Лівий берег, як вже на Східний туди їхати,
там є такий міст, який піднімається, під ним залізнична колія із заводу проходить.
І на цьому мосту були росіяни, військові, ну, я так зрозумів, ці ГРУшники.
Був Червоний Хрест представники. Це вперше і востаннє, коли я їх бачив за весь цей час.
Взагалі, безпонтова організація.
Це можна залишити в інтерв'ю, хай знають.
Так, Червоний Хрест - вони безпонтові.
Вони дали нам якісь там анкетки, це єдина від них користь.
Потім нас відвезли на Оленівку.
Ну, і на Оленівці були на бараках.
Це великі такі бараки, двоповерхові, там, як кімнати знаходяться.
Тобто, ми могли виходити, у дворі гуляти, там не зачинялися.
Ну, а в Оленівці не було взагалі працюючої каналізації, не працювала.
Виривав трактор цю яму, вони там купили ці туалети дерев'яні.
Я навіть не знав, що такі туалети виробляються, а там: зроблено, по-моєму, в "ДНР".
Ну, просто цілком туалет. Ну, і душ. Добре, що літо було, і там душ на вулиці водичкою.
Воду питну, умовно питну, привозили.
Але я так пробував ту воду, що привозили, і та, що йшла з крана, взагалі я ту, що з крану йшла, вона хоч зелена, але її хоч пити можна.
А та якоюсь хімією віддавала.
Потім був теракт на Оленівці, ну, це пам'ятаєте, всі бачили ці відео.
Взагалі, я чув ці вибухи, я думав, що прилетіло по їхньому розташуванню.
Думав: прилетіло, то прилетіло. Потім виявилося, що це наші.
Ну, там чутно було, полум'я було видно і чутно було, як цей шифер, він коли нагрівається, - стріляє.
І крики людей було чутно, які горять…
Багато загинуло. Багато поранених було.
Ну, взагалі, були такі… От у нас хлопець, він у мене був на "Залізяці" ще поранений, з пораненням руки.
Його потім на цей барак, ми його назвали барак 200.
Його на цей барак, де теракт відбувся, йому відірвало ще ногу, вибило око.
А йому там щось 22, може, роки, не пам'ятаю. Ну, і таких багато.
Тобто на Оленівці - це взагалі було шоком, тому що всі розуміли, що все, в полоні, в безпеці, ніхто не буде всіх стріляти.
А тут ні…
Це було, на мій погляд, це просто була така показова страта.
І потім нас на Таганрог відвезли.
З другого полону я вийшов 6 травня 2023 року.
Майже рік пробув у полоні, без двох тижнів.
Я вийшов з полону, важив 60 кілограмів.
Взагалі, у мене питають, яке було там харчування.
Ну, взагалі, їсти те, що було на Таганрозі, можна.
Але, як на мене, для людини з моїм метаболізмом, і взагалі те, що я до полону важив 93-95 в середньому,
для мене це було дуже мало. Плюс постійний стрес, ну, взагалі, він також спалює вагу.
Особисто для мене в другому полоні було важче, ніж у першому.
Так, тортури були. Саме навіть, якщо камера бачить, у мене пройшло більше чотирьох місяців, коли це було.
І в мене шрами так і не зажили, сліди від кайданок так і залишилися.
Довго просто в цих кайданках був, висів і позлазила шкіра.
І взагалі я навіть не звертався за медичною допомогою, вважав це взагалі не корисним у тих умовах.
Воно трошки повигнивало, довго загоювалося.
Це вже зараз, коли поміняли харчування, почало швидко загоюватися, а до цього не загоювалися поранення.
У мене була втрачена чутливість шкірних покровів.
Я тільки дотик відчував. Це приблизно від цих шрамів і до кінчиків пальців, отаким трикутником.
Дотик відчував, але на температуру: холодне або гаряче…
Я декілька разів обпалювався з цигаркою, бо не відчуваю жару від цигарки.
І зараз почав ходити на фізпроцедури і тільки почав відновлюватися.
Тобто там робили обстеження, перевіряли електропровідність нервів.
І кажуть, що нерви, які відповідають за рух, в нормі, а чутливість повинна протягом пів року поступово відновитися.
От, я навіть не знаю, коли в мене була зламана ця нога, коли робив КТ,
обстеження, виявилося, що в мене нога, бедро зламане було, 9 ребер.
Я пам'ятаю, що ребра боліли, а коли - навіть не пам'ятаю, коли зламали їх.
Ну, зуби – це вже в мене традиція, погана вже традиція, що зуби.
Добре, що це тимчасові коронки стояли, то вони випали.
Я намагався триматися, тому що, ще хлопці деякі питали: як ти після цих "пі…лів" усіх, блін, ще посміхаєшся?
Просто сидиш і намагаєшся просто не померти. Це краще, що ти можеш зробити.
У планах в мене, ну що, зараз закінчу лікування,
я не знаю, буде там реабілітація, чи потрібна вона мені, чи ні, то хай лікарі скажуть.
Ну, і повернутися, звісно, до служби.
У мене таке виходить, що перший раз я був ще в батальйоні, а повернувся в полк,
тут був у полку - повертаюся вже в бригаду. Ну, два рази - це вже достатньо, я маю на увазі полону.
Є така приказка: якщо ви не хочете годувати свою армію, то будете годувати іншу.
Це саме зараз про нас. Якщо ми хочемо відстояти свої території,
повернути свої території, повернути бранців наших, які знаходяться там,
то нам потрібно воювати. Росія думала, що ми миша якась,
на яку може наступити. Але велика тварина як слон дуже боїться мишей.
І ми, от саме Україна буде тією кісткою в горлі, від якої помирає вовк.
Дуже багато вони захотіли захопити, вони думали, що не буде спротиву, взагалі не буде спротиву.
Але це не та нація, яка не дає спротиву.
Звісно, що в нас багато людей полюбляють сумні пісні, посидіти, поплакати в інтернеті.
Але він посидів, поплакав в інтернеті, а потім витер свою сльозу, достав свою АР-ку,
одягнув свої берці, взяв свій наплічник і пішов воювати.
Така ми нація. І тому саме я буду продовжувати.